hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about RNA now usually when you hear the
word RNA you think mRNA tRNA and rRNA
those are not going to be our focus
today however if you are interested in
learning more about the role of mRNA
tRNA and rRNA in the central dogma and
protein synthesis and gene expression
and please see my video on the central
dogma of molecular biology but for today
we're going to learn about the type of
RNA that I like to call those other
types those types that we don't hear
about very often but are still of
critical importance in our physiology
so let's our very beginning RNA RNA
stands for ribonucleic acid and so that
acronym RNA actually comes from letters
in this term Ryo
fer nucleic at the end and acid FDA so
that's where we're getting that term RNA
now there are two major type of RNA
there is coding RNA that RNA which codes
for protein which we also know is mRNA
and it turns out that when RNA is
transcribed in a cell typically only
roughly 20% of the RNA in transcribe is
coding RNA a core the pointer varies
from cell type to cell type but the
other 80% approximately the other 80% of
RNA that's being transcribed in a cell
is actually in the other classification
of non-coding RNA the RNA types of
ribonucleic acids that do not code the
rest
we for protein and there are three main
types of non-coding RNA there are two
that we've heard a lot about are RNA
which is a principal component of
ribosomes in fact the catalytic
component of ribosomes and in tRNA which
we know of wrong translation the P RNA
is what brings the right amino acid to
the ribosome to be added to a growing
polypeptide chain so we know a lot about
this but today I want our focus to be
this other type of non-coding RNA which
is regulatory non-coding RNA or
regulatory NC RNA now then there are
many different kinds of regulatory
non-coding RNA I think the last time I
looked there were at least eight
different type known I'm sure that more
types will be discovered we continue our
exploration into the components that
make up a cell and help it to function
but for today I just want to talk about
my four favorite kinds of non-coding
regulatory non-coding RNA so the first
one is micro RNA it is abbreviated as M
I RNA and it is important in various
types of post term post transcriptional
regulation of gene expression what does
this mean we'll remember that
transcription is when an RNA transcript
is made from a DNA template so where the
information stored in a gene and DNA is
transcribed into RNA and then of course
you know that that transcript ends up
eventually being translated into protein
in the process of translation
however micro RNAs are functional in
regulating the gene expression at this
post transcriptional State
so basically once the transcript is made
it can then be further regulated by
micro RNA this means that micro RNAs can
cleave or degrade mRNA at various or
regulatory point so that mRNA can no
longer be translated so for example
let's say that a cell transcribed mRNA
in the process of transcription and then
that mRNA is translated a few times if
you protein they're made from it but
it's so no longer need those protein
it doesn't need to waste in energy and
resources making more of that protein so
micro RNA can come along and be great
that mRNA so that it is no longer being
translated specifically micro RNA is
made from single-stranded RNA which we
can abbreviate as SS RNA it formed
hairpin so basically one long single
strand of RNA that pulls back on itself
and puts a little bit to form a hairpin
and that's what it looks like it is
about twenty to twenty-four nucleotide
long the second type of regulatory
non-coding RNA I want to talk about is
small interfering RNA it is abbreviated
as si RNA and you'll see that its major
function is very similar to that of
micro RNA it also deals with post
transcriptional regulation of gene
expression so it can cleave or degrade
mRNA that is no longer needed by the
cell it can also degrade viral RNA since
we know that there are many viruses that
use RNA for their genetic material and
that viral RNA if it's found inside of a
cell where it's infecting
so small interfering RNA can help get
rid of it it is composed rather than the
single-stranded RNA that forms hairpin
is actually composed of double-stranded
RNA so we have read that is es RNA so
this is double-stranded RNA so two
strands of RNA where the nucleotides are
linked together a complementary
nucleotide linked together by hydrogen
bonds small interfering RNA also has
some interesting biotech applications
called RNA I the Stanford RNA
interference and this is where these
small non-coding RNA these are also
about 20 to 24 nucleotides in length
similar to the micro RNA up here about
the RNA i only small small interfering
RNAs si RNA can actually be added to a
cell in experiment in a laboratory in
order to control the cell post
transcriptional regulation of gene
expression so this is being used by
scientists to figure out you know what
different genes do in different
situations and different cell types and
a type of regulation that controls a
expression of various genes now let's go
on to the third type of regulatory
non-coding RNA and that is small nuclear
RNA which you Bri VA as SN RNA now small
nuclear RNA has a bit of a different
function rather than degrading or
cleaving mRNA if we talk about these
other types of regulatory non-coding
RNAs small nuclear rnas have a few
different types of functions one is to
help with processing a pre mRNA now
we've all heard many times that the
process of transcription
is when DNA is using the template to
make an RNA transcript now students will
sometimes forget that RNA transcript is
made by the RNA polymerase and
transcription that is not yet mrna it's
actually pre-mrna pre mRNA has to be
further processed for example in
eukaryotes that need the five prime cap
added it needs a poly a tail it needs to
be spliced so the introns are spliced
out only the exons remain and so forth
and so that that process where Mr where
pre mRNA is modified to turn it into
fully mature mRNA that is regulated by
different kinds of snrnas as been rnase
also regulates transcription factors now
transcription factors are small proteins
that are used in the process of
transcription
we know the transcription uses that big
RNA polymerase to make that RNA
transcript from the DNA template but
there are various types of transcription
factors that help to sort of initiate
transcription to help it run
functionally and an L bit often
correctly and also to aid in the
termination of transcription and so the
activity of those transcription factors
and the expression of those
transcription factors is regulated by
small nuclear RNA moments your RNA also
are important in maintaining to Lanier's
T Lanier's
are long repetitive stretches of DNA at
the ends of our chromosomes now we know
that in prokaryotes their chromosome is
at least a circular chromosome but in
eukaryotes like humans we have linear
chromosomes and so the ends of those
chromosomes are kind of fragile and they
can be degraded over time
after the phallus divided so many times
with telomeres are sort of getting
shorter and so those telomeres are those
long repetitive stretches of DNA at the
end of our chromosome that protect our
chromosomes and keep actual genes from
being degraded away and so those
telomeres are maintained in part through
activity by small nuclear RNA now you
can see that the small nuclear RNA in
addition to having a different set of
functions and these other two non-coding
RNA as we've talked about that if they
all go to different lengths they're
about 150 nucleotides long so quite a
bit longer than my ribbon micro rna's
and small interfering RNA so now to wrap
up this video let's talk about the
fourth type of regulatory non-coding RNA
and that is long non-coding RNA these
are abbreviated as Ln C RNA so LM crn a
often called link RNA so link RNA are
important for regulating chromatin
modifications if you're interested in
learning about how DNA is packed around
histone and pass so that it can fit in
that very small cell nucleus then you
should see my other video on DNA packing
and histone now when DNA is passed into
chromatin and it's wrapped around those
histones there are various types of
regulatory processes that control which
sections of DNA are tightly wrapped and
which are sort of unwrapped and made
accessible for transcription let me
repeat that transcription needs a DNA
template to make an RNA transcript of a
gene in the DNA the DNA is often really
tightly wrapped around histone proteins
and very tightly packed together into
this chromatin like structure and the
chromatin can be modified through
various types of course biochemical tags
input methyl group or fetal groups and
the types of modifications present
control which DNA is open and available
to be transcribed and which DNA is
closed and not available to be
transcribed and linked rnase regulate of
processes of which types of DNA are
available to be transcribed at different
times now link RNA also regulate various
parts of transcription they regulate
blessings I've already mentioned once in
this video slicing where introns are
spliced out a comma splice together to
result in that fully functional mature
and RNA that is ready to be translated
and interestingly weak RNA also regulate
the activity of micro RNA and small
interfering RNA so we see that there are
these really fascinating levels of
regulation where this art type of RNA
regulate certain things and this type
regulate certain things and they are
themselves regulated by other types of
RNA and we see that there are all of
these levels of different kind of
regulation which really gives to sell a
lot of control over its internal
processes and then just through further
wrapping that long non-coding RNA you
won't be surprised from that name long
it is the longest of the bunch coming in
at over two hundred nucleotides long
compared to maybe 150 or 2224 so these
are the different
types of RNA that are very critical to
proper functioning of yourself which we
don't often hear about so I hope that
you learned a lot from this video today
if you're interested in learning more
about the processing of pre in learning
at five prime cap the poly a tail the
splicing then I also have a video on
that topic and I hope you will check it
out thank you for watching biology
professor